(seagulls crying)
- I like this. This is nice.
People should see this.
(camera click)
(Phone chimes)
Oh geez, everyone is getting
political these days.
(phone chimes)
Oh my gosh, that is foul language.
Too stressful.
That's why I've never voted.
- You've never voted?
- Holy shit! You guys can talk?
- Yeah, he's right. You need to vote.
Everyone knows that.
- Well, how do I know who to vote for?
What if I vote for the wrong person?
- Well, it depends what issues
are most important to you.
- For instance, I am sick and
tired of foreign cabana boys
coming in here and taking
American cabana boy jobs.
- And I have a ton of debt
racked up from cabana boy college
so I'm votin' for a candidate
that will help with that.
- Cabana boy college loan companies
need to make a profit, Luke.
- Okay, I don't even know what
you guys are talking about.
How did you learn this?
- Basically asking questions
and figurin' out what's important.
- Okay wait, so you're telling me
if I want to get political,
I have to leave this beach and figure out
what's important to me?
- May I suggest your ability
to purchase an automatic rifle?
(gun cocking)
- Gun rights? What about poverty?
- You socialist pig!
- You racist monster!
I'm with her!
- Build the wall!
- This is crazy!
I don't even know which side I'm on,
if I'm on any side at all.
- I'm with her!
- Build the wall!
- I guess it's time to
learn how to be political.
- I'm with her!
- Build the wall!
I'm with her! I'm with her!
(seagulls crying)
(electronic music)
- [Kelsey Voiceover] As smart
as those cabana boys were,
I wanted to get an expert's
perspective on getting political
so I went back to college to speak
to a professor of Political Science.
That's right, Science!
- My question is are all
elections this stressful?
Level with me.
How do people get a grasp on politics?
- As Abe Lincoln said, "By
the people, of the people,
for the people."
How do the people even
know what is going on?
How do they know what are the issues?
It is media.
I think it's incumbent on people
to look at different sources.
Donald Trump is the surprise candidate
and he's certainly not the darling
of the Republican establishment.
- No, I would say not.
- So how did he get to be the candidate?
It was through votes.
- [Kelsey Voiceover] Go figure,
that professor actually knew
what she's talkin' about.
If I really want to learn about politics,
I have to talk to multiple sources, okay?
I can't just be brainwashed
by social media feeds.
So, I hopped on a plane and flew
to the greatest show of earth,
- The Republican National
Convention in Cleveland!
(heavy electronic music)
It's hot. My spanx are sticking to my ass.
So this is actually my first year voting.
Why should I vote for Trump?
- I really love Trump's
stance for America first.
I know that he's not really a Republican
so that really turns me on.
- He's not?
- I don't think he is.
- Turns you on?
- Yes!
- Were you sayin' you would
have sex with Donald Trump?
- Absolutely.
- Really?!
Why should we vote for Trump? We're young.
- Well, I think we should
be the most concerned
because we have a lot of
uncertainty about our future.
- Hey, listen to the man with the gun.
Millennials do have a lot at stake.
Okay, we're gonna be the ones
living with these decisions
a lot longer than anyone
else voting but still,
we vote less than Baby Boomers.
For instance, in 2012, only
46% of Millennials voted
compared to 69% of Baby Boomers?
If anything, we should be
voting 69% and not our parents!
(sigh)
- Yeah but now I'm learning and this is
the whole fucking video's about.
Shut the fuck up, Shane. I'm gonna vote.
Can I touch your gun?
- Oh yeah, poke it. (laughs)
(cartoon-like poking sound)
There you go.
- They sent me over to Vietnam in 1969.
- I saw that '69.
- But now they're a big
trading partner with us.
They make hats and they make tennis shoes.
- Your hat?
You remind me of my Dad, kind of.
- Oh, thank you.
- Trump has talked about a Muslim ban.
That kinda seems totally
against freedom of religion
which like isn't that
what our country's about?
- Heck, that's the First Amendment.
- Heck!
- One of our fundamental
rights, freedom of religion.
Absolutely.
- Let's talk about the wall.
- Ah, yes.
- What?
Who's paying for that?
Is it even gonna work?
- Does the President
have the authority to say
we're building a wall?
- Does he?
- If you look in the Constitution, nah,
that seems to be something
he's got to work out with Congress.
We don't have a King.
- You can't speak for me. Man.
- No.
- I set my own opinions.
- Well, right? Remember, we the people.
We vote 'em in and we can vote ya out.
- Hey ya, you hear that?
Don't be doin' anything stupid
'cause we, we have the power.
- More important than anything,
you have to know what is important to you.
For me, self-dense, Second
Amendment, is very important.
I'm a Constitutionalist.
I carry my pocket
Constitution everywhere I go.
The second page I mark
is the Tenth Amendment
and that states that any
job not granted through
the federal government,
article one, section A,
the Constitution grants, we the people -
- You know, I just read Twitter.
That's really where I get all my news.
I follow a lot of different
political correspondents.
Do your research on the down-ballot.
That's gonna be more important.
- What the fuck is a down-ballot?
- So the down-ballot is gonna
be your gubernatorial races,
your senate races, your local congressmen,
stuff like abortion, I just
couldn't stay away from,
you should be able to
do whatever you want.
I mean, goodness, the marriage -
- Oh my God, I think I'm in love with you.
- There's no excuse for
not doing your research.
We have the internet now.
I try and look up both parties
and all candidates by pages.
Most do have their own websites
and just put them into Google.
- LGBTQ issues are important to me.
- Yes.
- Yeah and women's rights
issues are very important to me.
I'm scared to get my rights taken away.
- I would like more reform
on how you fund colleges
because we're both college students -
- I dropped out of
colleges. Three of them.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, well, you know. I drank a lot.
It was a whole thing.
(vomiting)
- Honestly, I am against abortion.
- But what if they got in a situation
that they don't want kids?
- I understand. I don't judge.
- You wear condoms?
So it seems like Donald
Trump doesn't really care
about women's rights and LGBT
issues which is a big thing
that I care about.
- [Kelsey Voiceover] But I
don't really know how Hillary
would address these issues
as President either.
But look, I found out what I cared about
and that's my first tip.
Find out what issues are important to you.
- As much as the people in Cleveland were,
I needed to hear from the other side
of the political spectrum too.
So, I flew to the Democratic
National Convention.
It's hot as shit
here in Philadelphia.
(crowd cheering)
Man there are a ton of people out here.
- Are you startin' to form opinions?
- I mean, listen, I'm a very loud person
but I feel like I don't really have
a lot of important stuff to say.
It's intimidating, you know?
- Do you think all of these people
have important things to say?
- They sure sound like it.
- [Crowd] It's a movement, not a moment.
- At least they don't have
an open carry law here.
- That's true.
- You know, I think the greatest
danger is if people say,
I'm not gonna get involved, what the heck,
it doesn't matter,
that's not how democracy
is supposed to work.
- This is actually gonna
be my first year voting.
What should I care about?
- The people and what's
best for each other.
- Most people are assholes though.
As Millennials, what would
you say to other young people
that are saying, well, I don't
really like either person
so I'm just not gonna vote?
- Vote for somebody.
As long as you're having a
say in what happens to you,
that's what matters.
- It's not just red and blue.
It's green, yellow, purple, fuchsia.
- We need to get rid of the people
that are currently running.
There are four branches to
the American government.
- Oh, can I guess?
- Go ahead.
- Judicial, legislative, uh -
- Executive, and what's the fourth branch?
- Independent.
(buzzer)
- We the people.
- Oh.
- People need to start payin' attention.
- And llamas get attention.
- It's hard to ignore the big fluffy thing
walkin' down the road.
- I'm not sayin' that the
presidential race is not important
but what's happenin' on the
local level is important.
That determines where the
money goes for your schools,
your libraries, your roads,
and all the infrastructure.
- And as an academic
professor, I challenge students
and young people to think critically.
Don't just accept the status
quo and so your opinion
and your voice and your vote does count
and it does matter.
- I, personally, of course,
would not vote for Trump.
Hillary is like your vegetable.
You don't really want
it but it's good for you
and then you have your
Donald Trump who's like
the McDonald's that no one actually admits
that they like to eat.
- Oh, shit!
(laughter)
- What you doin' out here?
- What a surprise.
I wasn't expectin' to see you here today.
You were just in Cleveland.
- Just a blink away.
- Now who did you say when
we talked to you first
that you liked?
- It's Trump. It's definitely Trump.
- Feel a, flip flopin', I see.
- Of course.
He's about business, y'all.
- I feel you.
That guy's right.
Elections are about business, y'all.
Get this shit.
As of August 31st 2016,
the Trump and Clinton campaigns together
have spent over $1 billion.
That's billion with a B
as in, bitch, that's a lot of money.
People receiving that money include:
campaign workers, TV networks,
merchandise manufacturers,
people who rent office space and stadiums,
security, travel companies,
if you've got an industry,
it's hard not to be impacted
by the money spent in an election.
As someone who avoided
politics like the plague,
this conversation has
definitely sparked something
inside of me to get involved
and want to learn more.
- And that's what politics is all about,
having the conversation
to make a better world.
- So I should take my voting
responsibility seriously.
- And you should rejoice in
having a real say in a way
that people in many countries do not have.
- Do you want to rejoice with me?
- Ah, yes, hallelujah!
(angels singing)
- So after a week of gettin' learned on
by Democrats and Republicans,
I needed a goddamn drink
so I went to one of our
nation's oldest bars,
the City Tavern and, holy
shit, that's Benjamin Franklin.
Hello, I'm Kelsey.
- Kelsey, what brings you here?
- Beer.
- Beer?
Huzzah to you all.
- Huzzah!
(harp music)
What are your thoughts on the
shit that's happening today?
Are you happy with it?
Do you think you laid a good foundation?
- The language on this woman.
- Oh, I know. Times are
different, let me tell you.
- Is that what they call a millennial?
- Yes.
- Well, I remember being a Federalist.
- What do Federalists believe?
- Democracy, a stable government,
the freedom of religion
which the Declaration is also about.
- Well, let me tell 'ya, Benny.
Some shit has changed.
So there's these two people.
One guy's named Donald Trump.
- Never heard of him.
- And then there's Hillary who might be -
- A woman?
- The first female President.
What do you think about that?
- Very odd.
- We're gonna play a little
bit of government trivia.
You've been very involved with
American politics this week.
- Tell me 'bout it.
- We're gonna ask you a question.
If you get the answer correct -
- I drink and if I get it wrong,
you guys get to drink.
- We drink.
- When was a woman first
allowed to vote in this country?
- Fuck, I should know this.
- Yeah.
- Was it 18's or 19's?
- 19's.
- Now that's fucked up.
I'm gonna go with 1920.
- That's it! That's it!
- 1920!
- That's it, you did it!
Don't say another word.
- Well done, drink.
- Okay, okay.
- Drink as much as you can.
- Here's a good one.
Who is Gary Johnson?
- He's a Republican.
(buzzer)
- No.
- He's an Independent.
(buzzer)
- He's a green -
- No, keep goin'.
- He's a Liberal.
(buzzer)
- No.
- Shit.
- He's running for the Libertarian Party.
- I said he's a liberal!
- No.
- Well, it's a different thing.
- Liberal and Libertarian
are very, very different.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
- So it's turns out those
straight white men are right.
People talk about a politial spectrum
which usually goes from
conservative to liberal.
Now, Republicans are conservative
and Democrats are liberal
but opposite sides of the spectrum, right?
Turns out Libertarians
are more conservative
than Republicans!
Unless we're talking about weed,
then that goes somewhere over here.
Other than those, there
are the Green Party,
the Constitution Party,
the Peace and Freedom Party
and a whole bunch of other small ones,
not to mention Independents.
So find someone who likes
what you like even if that's
on a local level and vote for them.
Yeah, I gotta honestly be honest with you.
- Please do.
- I didn't think I was ever gonna vote.
- Really?
- I'm realizing how much
I'm gonna be affected after
this election and how much
my opinions do matter to me.
Yeah.
Alright, it's time for me to ask you guys
a little trivia question.
- Oh, my God.
- Jesus Christ.
- Hope you got your drinks ready.
Am I on my period right now?
- If we knew that, I feel -
- No, you're not 'cause you haven't gone
to the bathroom enough if you were.
(gasp)
- Oh!
(laughter)
- [Kelsey Voiceover] After
speaking to supporters
and academics across the country,
I flew back to California
where I'm finally ready
to actually vote
but I don't know how
to actually vote.
I mean, can I do it online here?
What's this?
Oh, this looks interesting.
- Hello?
Hello?
Is this a place that I can vote?
- Hello!
- Hi!
Welcome to the puppet polling place.
Thanks for showing up.
- Of course.
I've finally found out
what issues matter to me
so now I'm here to learn how to vote.
- We love to help.
- Yeah, like, love, love it.
- That's really comforting.
- Now, are you registered to vote?
- Oh, I don't know. How do I find out?
- Online!
- Yeah, online!
- Go to vote.usa.gov and they can help ya.
- Yeah, they'll help you good.
- You can vote in-person or by mail.
- In-person on Election Day,
go to your polling place.
- Oh wait, back up. I
don't know where that is.
- Well, how'd you find us?
- Online.
- There you go!
- Duh!
Once you find out where to vote,
go there and cast your vote.
- But what if I can't leave
work or I'm out of town
or I'm lazy?
- Well, then you get
to cast a mail-in vote.
- Yay, mail!
- Yeah, mail.
First you request a mail-in ballot.
You fill it out and you mail it in.
- Thank you puppets.
I'm so thankful for your help.
Bye!
So there you have it.
A motherfucker got political.
Turns out being political isn't that hard.
You just have to figure
out what matters to you.
Should be pretty easy.
Figure out what candidate
also cares about those issues.
That's a little bit harder.
Register to vote. Just do
it online for Christ's sake.
Go out there and do the goddamn thing.
I know you've heard it
before but it's true.
You need to go out there and vote.
And once you do,
boom,
affecting change in your community
and ultimately
the world.
It's very philosophical.
It's very much outside of ourselves.
We are a part of something bigger.
Neil deGrasse Tyson, guys. 20/20.
- [Male] Does he say that?
- No.
- [Male] Are you quoting him directly?
- No, I just think it'd be
dope if he was President.
He's a real nice guy.
Anyhoo.
Hey guys, that was the first
episode of my new show,
Am I Doing This Right?
It was fucking good, right?
It's basically like a crash
course on how to be a grown-up
even if you don't feel like one.
The rest of the series drops
in December only on Watchable.
Plus, all this election
crap will be over by then
and we can celebrate that by
watching Am I Doing This Right?
December!
(film reel)
- [Narrator] Watchable.